telling stories has been ingrained in
our culture years years ahead and I hate
millennium millennium since the
beginning from cave paintings don't
having to literature and film there have
been countless ways that human beings
have tried to tell their stories be them
true or make-believe and share them down
through generations I feel like it's an
important part of simply being human we
feel such an array of emotions and we go
through so many great and hard
situations that it's quite difficult to
show others exactly what is going on
inside for the best way to do that is to
simply tell it in a story listening to
great stories help us empathize with
others and also a great source of
entertainment
they help us understand the worlds that
came before we were born and get to know
not only ourselves at each other better
so when it comes to visual storytelling
the first thing that will come into
people's heads is probably film films
have been around for a long long time
now as a brilliant sort of entertainment
as a way of taking stories from the
artistic paper format to something
that's actually a moving image in front
of you the closest thing to real life
however now there's also gain and I want
to talk about views on games being able
to tell stories as well as film and what
differences there are between the two
medium now the main difference between
games and films when telling a narrative
through their platform is that a film
director has a vision they know how they
want to tell their story from start to
finish they know how they want the
audience to perceive the story sometimes
there are cliff hangers and things like
that however games are entirely
different games need to be driven and
manipulated by the audience by the play
for the story to unravel and most of the
time that story can change due to the
player's actions
I feel like games now
comes at a natural part of our culture a
couple of decades ago games were nowhere
near to the peak that they are nowadays
if you heard the words game back then
and perhaps some people now it still
means simply a game that is for
entertainment value something that you
do that has a leveling up system
probably involved from shooting probably
involve something a little bit vulgar
and that's what game through seen as
however there is such a wide array of
games now that I think is quite
different want to find someone who
doesn't play a game the questions do you
play games now seems so trivial it seems
just a silly to say that if someone as
it does to say do you watch film because
of course we all watch feel who doesn't
like to sit down what's a good new
hearing element and it's becoming the
same with game against a rapidly
developed in the past couple of decades
they have run out to other devices and
also other types of games other genres
now the main question if you want to
understand someone's taste in film and
narrative would be what sort of genre do
you like to want and I believe that's
the same for gaming do you like
role-playing games do you like best
present shooters we like indie game I
guess a good question would be why do we
watch films in the first place why do we
want to get a mass in a whole new
narrative whole new story the most
obvious answer to that question is
escaping from time out from the real
world from the world that we know and
getting lost in someone else's vision of
what the world could be alternate world
and imagination that simply doesn't
exist in the world around you right now
films can help you shut off they can
help you regain your strengths when
you're feeling low nor so they can help
educate you many people do see game
Interiors film and i guess it's because
it's a newer platform a newer medium and
not as many people understand it as well
as we do film I found critical Roger
Ebert basically said that games were
inferior to film valid reason
he stated that video games were a loss
of precious hours that we have to become
more civilized empathetic and well
cultured no II understand where he'd get
there are many films that help us to
understand the mistakes possibly that
humankind has made in the past
so just Schindler's List many very
moving pieces but who's to say that
games haven't done the same and aren't
capable of doing the same many people
see games as simply just a source of
entertainment but they can be so much
more and when you think about empathy I
can't think of a better way to the broke
empathy from someone and to really put
them and mast in the narrative I have
them at the center of the interaction
between what happens throughout that
narratives putting the control in their
hands makes them feel more at one with
the story that's being told to them they
have the power they have the control
they are the driving force therefore
everything that happens is because of
them how can they not feel empathy
personable gain such as gearbox which is
made to open people's eyes about using
drones in the war it's a very
interesting game because it might not be
necessarily what you think of when you
think of games but it's still got the
same mechanics it's a multiplayer and
one person plays running around in the
scenery and another person it's
controlling a drone and trying to kill
fests and targets and Morphin or not
they end up killing the other person who
is running around doing nothing on the
foot might seem like maybe a boring game
perhaps but it really opened people's
eyes to realize that when you are
controlling the
if you have no idea what you're feeling
on the floor and their partner the other
person who is playing they didn't know
what was coming and they died so it's
very dull really tough topic sorry but I
just want to show you though games can
be used for something much more than
simply just sitting down and having fun
and provider editor say that game don't
make us more civilized more empathetic
when you think of a game such as kill
box I would say it's quite the opposite
now relevance these games that were
obviously designed to provoke a certain
nature there are much bigger title games
that are being told as series kind of
taking the twist from television and
making it more interactive and immersive
such as telltale game series or life is
strange you can see plenty of fingers on
YouTube alone of people getting very
emotional and actually crying over the
decisions that were presented to them
within the game I don't sleep myself up
because I read and once certain
carriages to die and things like that
because you feel like you are one with
games and you have a part if you don't
pick up that controller and make those
tough decisions and carry on playing the
narrative stops the story ends there and
that's all down to you that's a good for
a bad thing because with a filmed an
artist goes on no matter whether you
want it or not I guess you do turn off
the TV but you don't have to typically
do anything you can just sit there and
enjoy it but with a game you have to be
the driving force in my mind that makes
the message more powerful as well as the
emotions of these sorts games provoke I
think they also have quite an
interesting future ahead of them at the
end of these games you get to see what
choices you have made in comparison to
everyone else paper game I don't mean in
your circle of friends I mean in the
world
you get to see percentages of whether
you were within the majority of people
or the minority and that is so
interesting
not only learning about yourself and how
you might deal with tough situations
you're learning about how mankind deals
with tough situations where tough
situations I'm talking euthanasia close
people death trying to helps along with
the suicide
these games are touched on very dark
matters but because they're gain they
can get away with it because even though
they feel real to an extent they will
always be a game and yes this might seem
like they're not as good as films
because film commits themselves look so
real but when you are in again and
you're actually within the narrative
you're there you're feeling you're
making the big decisions you still need
that detachment or that emotion to
perhaps get a bit too much in a future
using these sorts of percentages to see
how people react to certain situations
can be used on a larger scale I'm not
too sure what exactly but I just find
that using these games in these really
big situations to find out how human
beings feel on certain topics that
perhaps they wouldn't talk about in
their day-to-day life or they wouldn't
really understand because they'd never
been through it to be really good
research somewhere down the line it's
interesting to see as well the array of
interactive film films using things like
WebGL or interlude where they're mashing
together loads of different video files
and crossing them over depending on what
the computer wants to see it seems like
they're kind of there and on the
interactive route of gaming I've also
seen films using WebGL to make
interactive charts and things like that
over videos which i think that are
really interesting like a bit a
real-time chart in sailor documentary
and it would always be relevant it would
never have to be updated and the data
there would always be great at whatever
time you're watching the video so it's
very interesting how these interactive
elements can be used to focus film and
and Maurice excited because I can slowly
see the magic president's game designers
have already seemed to want to try and
go down the route of film Ken Levine
Prince's to close the mastermind behind
Bioshock and BioShock Infinite frickin
love Bioshock he is working on a
interactive film series using interlude
all about the twilight zone and I'm very
interested to see where he goes with
that and it's just very exciting to see
that he's thinking outside of the gaming
environment he wants to make another
game as well however you want to try and
make this film serious but keep an
interactive element in it because that's
what comes from the game universe as
well as that there's people like Hideo
machine who was the mastermind behind
Metal Gear Solid and he came from a film
background he didn't coming from a game
one he had always loved films and even
though he might have been really good at
the start of his career
this film knowledge brought in a new way
of thinking about gaming such as a
message a solid when he made you battle
Psycho Mantis and play commented read
your memory card a new book game you
were playing and made you remove your
controller from port 1 to port 2 to
actually beat him it's a narrative
physically left your screen and made you
get up off your couch on your bed and
spit me do something and that is amazing
and also right now Hiroshima is red with
yellow Deltora which is amazing it's
mashing up an awesome film director with
a great game designer and I can't wait
for death drowning it's going to be
great they've already made such
beautiful game trailers and PG was a
masterpiece in itself anyway but I guess
what I'm trying to get at here is that
film and games should gladly merge and I
think they are which is amazing but
it's originally how their scene has two
completely different platforms when
they're both giving the same thing film
seems to have more direction they have
more precise control buying their
directors
however games have this unique ability
to really put the viewer in these
fictional world and within these
narratives to make them feel emotions
like they've never felt before
why not master - I believe if you stick
to one medium and you specialize too
much you start to not be able to think
outside the box
people like Hideo Kojima and what can
they are you doing they are able to
think outside the box because they're
getting their inspiration from other
sources that aren't just within their
own industry and that's what needs to be
done to push the boundaries of narrative
and storytelling to make something
entirely new so I believe that instead
of thinking which one's better we should
just be thinking what are the best parts
of both and how can we move them
together to make something truly unique
and really empowering to whoever watches
it because yes filming games could be
merely for entertainment but they can
also be really eye-opening they can help
us escape from our worries or they can
help us understand the worries of others
and worldly matters that are going on
and relevant right now when you play a
game or watch a film it's much easier to
take in information and it lingers with
you afterwards so I do believe that it's
important to take these platforms
seriously both of them not just one and
try and make them better
so that is my opinion on the gaming and
the filming industry when thinking about
narrative and storytelling it's a very
important topic to me and I really over
got it across okay but that is exactly
why I am studying game development even
though I am a masters lover of film and
always have been and I really hope that
I can just wreck in an industry that is
working towards using the best of both
of these mediums to push the boundaries
of storytelling have fun with it but
also make the best impact that we can on
the universe and the world enough to
the future incoming film and gay
Marshall and I'm stripping exploited
thanks for isn't you ramble about my
love of games and films I hope this was
moderately interesting to listen to if
you have any of your own thoughts on it
please do write them in the comment
section bellow and have a lovely day or
evening bye
[Music]
you